mais pour commencer Lucas le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire était en
déplacement en Touren aujourd'hui
accompagné d'Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué au PME il a recueilli ce matin
les doléances de plus de 200
entrepreneurs l'objectif lancer les
rencontres de la simplification pendant
plusieurs mois le ministre consultera
les professionnels de la France entière
puis formulera une série de mesures pour
simplifier la vie des entreprises
Faustine luno était sur
place la salle est pleine 250
entrepreneurs artisans et un sont venus
adresser leurs plaines et leur requêes
au ministre Bruno Le Maire et Olivia
Grégoire la cible aujourd'hui la
paperace du quotidien puisquon payait
les cotaxes on devait plus payer pour
refaire traiter nos déchets et
aujourd'hui on continue à faire payer
déchets et on paye des cotaxes je sais
qu'on est 600 agriculteurs enrir à ne
pas avoir reçu nos aides d j'en fait
partie aussi également et lorsque
j'achète des produits à 1 € 2 € ou 10 €
sur une brente personne ne veut me
donner sa pièce d'identité pour l'objet
que j'achète et la solution qui consiste
à assouplir le marché du travail c'est
pouvoir faire des mini contrats première
d'une longue série de consultations
partout en France jusqu'à début 2024
cette rencontre avait deux objectifs
faire l'état des lieux des freins qui
pèsent sur les entreprises en
particulier au niveau administratif mais
aussi recueillir des propositions de
solution pour simplifier leur vie chose
comme je l'ai ressenti après 2 heur
d'échange ici beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
n'en peuvent plus ils en peuvent plus la
complexité ils en peuvent plus des
délais ils en peuvent plus de la
suspicion à leur égard ils en peuvent
plus d'avoir toujours plus de normes
toujours plus de règles mais c'est notre
rôle d'entendre ces réactions et
d'apporter des réponses en plus de ces
rencontres une consultation en ligne est
ouverte depuis hier permettant de donner
des idées et son avis via des votes déjà
près de 1000 solutions ont été suggérées
et 45000 votes effectués la majeure
partie des entrepreneurs on est
confronté au même à la même
problématique le fait qu'il y ait un
échange on a l'impression d'être écouté
ce qui est important maintenant il faut
qu'on soit entendu et que la démarche
aille vraiment au bout du bout d'ici au
29 décembre toutes les fédérations
pourront adresser leurs propositions aux
deux rapporteurs de l'Inspection
générale des finances et du conseil
général de l'économie avec tout de même
un frein budgétaire non négligeable ces
solutions devront exclure la fiscalité
et ne pas coûter au budget de
l'État y